[Music]
guys whether you're a pro or an iron
league MVP anybody who's ever touched a
keyboard a mouse or a joystick knows
that feeling of pure dread when you
realize just how [ __ ] you and your
team really are will close out map
number 116 to elect 1508 knowing you're
well and truly [ __ ] and not being able
to do a thing about it is honestly
something we can all relate to so we
thought it would be fun to rank those
humbling moments when things in-game
didn't quite go as well as they did in
your head without further ado here are
the top 10 moments you know your Fox
kicking off our list is the common
mistake of screwing up your Flash my
eldest I fight oh my god they so perfect
now messing up a flash can apply to both
League of Legends and shooters gas
canisters still in play from Willem I'm
not sure what he was thinking there full
blind
Bosco start speaking around the corner
prop did with the kill but regardless of
what game you're playing when the flash
goes wrong you know you're [ __ ]
everyone is our best there we go come on
[Music]
look at faker everybody switch out of
that flash he wasn't counting on Edwards
being in such syllabuses and that's the
issue right JW is just gonna go for the
peak but that's the issue you believe
you throw the fine down dredge line out
that stick it keeps more and in place
even the best players in the world will
flash into the wall at number nine is
when you scout the enemy cheese too late
hey man want some cheese before long
whether it involves a literal scout all
of my sister is still waiting the
patience game coming I can spot them
coming out of suite door while he's here
he sees them now they're straight
headshot they have no idea Smith's
looking confused and dazed or it doesn't
with that sound berry codepen there are
not expecting this master at all as he
comes in from the side and there it is
doing work with the bastion he gets to
evermore low as well as a nano boost for
right art but it's over time they need
to get on to the point and they may have
done it got tanked take time goodbye
evermore you're not gonna make it and
that does it take four LW blue what an
epic cheese by the time you sniff it out
it's probably too late for you the
double/double proxy game with a forge
and well clocks certainly wanted this to
be an entertaining series
and I'm seeing something that I've never
seen before I don't understand right now
yes it is aircraft coming in at number
eight is a moment that's happened to
everybody the stakes are high your
team's counting on you and all you have
to do is properly aim your mouse and
left-click is it miss quite a few pistol
shots Kenny yes II wanna kill the round
whether it's your shots
it's a retake for the two rollers
joystick will not know what joystick
turns on you know absolute destruction
your skills under the gun here as they
are faster double trouble for DC your
uppercuts or whatever it may be the
other difficulty is a lot of their
passes are going all it takes is one
mistake in overtime but I didn't think
it would be that quickly oh my goodness
freaky God gets away the worst part
about whipping is you have just enough
time afterwards to realize just how
[ __ ] you really are no matter what
game you play time is always of the
essence which is why our number seven
spot goes to running out of time
but also another healing
again with the healing yes when you're
in the heat of battle it's pretty easy
to tunnel vision and forget about the
clock ticking away in the corner they're
gonna need to go for a plant marks
coming out he just needs to solid hide
but the time is in there are slash you
do I to live clone nine what are you
doing it if there's anything to learn
from this entry it's that time is never
on your side
CLG they will pick this up 16 to 12 they
went out the series in a 2-1 fashion it
was lengthy but it we don't know who the
power is no time
no but it's that moment of pure panic
and realization where everything goes
downhill
[Applause]
targets
[Applause]
coming in at number six it's a trap
whether it's a literal trap or a
strategic bait bait is Lane there's a
small blood patch where actual bullets
wrap and it is trapped because they came
to check for it
now this gun bigger I don't know they're
gonna bring it down oh boy
now when the beat is the Swedes they
pull something out of the bag and feet
is gonna go down as well Oh hunter no
one has ever done that no one's ever
done that in the history of DOTA when
you realize that you've been a pawn in
the enemy's plan the whole time well
there's not much more to say Oh does
this turn off come postilion small so
he's fighting you we can sort of walk
out what I'll try doing I think he's
gonna either he's gonna either switch -
we don't make this the merry-go-round
cuz that makes me laugh makes me happy
in short ball switches to the Widowmaker
just the right time clothes are drops
down and today the shooting range for
Lane Roberts a Canadian superstar on a
Spitfire
completely smashed up until now our list
is focused on moments that we all as
gamers can relate to but not this one
[ __ ] under the bus direct me only a
select few players have experienced that
moment of dread that comes with
realizing that simple has joined the
server which is why it comes in at
number 5 on our list 14 seconds they've
gotta get out simple get some we want to
return jumps up and somehow point Sergey
but he hasn't found the bomb he will now
and he goes away from default - wait I
don't want to get native he also knows
lose the plank and he also knows he
needs was yeah actually get the first
one he's got a chance he knows a lose up
this is simple and it isn't one on three
breaking becomes possible yeah first oh
my god the player jumps straight into a
bomb planted simple yet dad misses the
shot missed huh he turns around he turns
around sir he was on the pistol how does
simple win these how does he do it every
single time seriously you don't have to
take our word for it because even the
pros agree with us well he makes me so
good like I said before bro the guys got
amazing talent and he's aggressive and
he's got big balls and game like he will
take all the jewels possible and he's
got the skill to back it at number four
on our list is that moment you need to
make a shot
use your super or drop your alt and then
you realize well you can't oh she does
have reincarnation only just barely
though man about him there are plenty of
different resources across all the
different eSports on Rose you can run
out of bullets actually gonna sneak in
behind and that's oh we didn't know we
had to reload on frames flusher in their
back lines he's out of
my visa what's happening
[Music]
out of mana wait I miscounted I wouldn't
kill them
I'm so [ __ ] bad or even calories this
should be enough oh your ease and then
get shot at this point the only resource
left to run out of is health no mana you
have no mana [ __ ] the number three
entry on our list is that moment you see
a piece of deadly ordnance flying right
at you
[Applause]
let's be real here guys there's just not
much to do when a grenade lands right at
your feet you focused on mercs with the
AWP to control against Guardian but oh
my moose hindi do you need all that
beautiful prover turns right back into
it just know that whatever the explosive
may be running is futile it's best to
just sit there close your eyes and
accept your fate this moment
it's beautiful
get brained on goes yeah with the don't
our runner-up spot goes to the moment
you hear that dreadful sound cue that
signals your own demise that's right
it's the moment you realize that you and
quite possibly your team are about to
get dunked on by an enemy ultimate oh my
god help us all teabag him with it
Wow they would not expect see that SK
just got it destroyed
[Applause]
kills patients from zone waiting in the
wave now he is about to be caught
oh there's been sleep lizard he catches
everyone oh this could be a total
disaster
thank you everyone
Danny
that's why I'm trying to survive
Schwantz gonna go down let me talk about
the Nagas counter its lineup Evan what
this BKB they turn it around you might
see it coming you might hear it coming
but it's always too late it doesn't get
any worse than this
that's right taking the number one spot
on our list is that short moment when
you're still alive but rendered
completely useless by CC they've grabbed
Moochie know my hero and even if you
happen to survive the C C's duration by
the time it runs out everything around
you has likely gone to [ __ ] looking
great so far top set goes down really
that's just funny other bleep dark odd
facility right after he pulls out the
dragonblade South Korea just unstoppable
here PPT he comes the ice blasts or
anything
[Applause]
now guys I know in the intro I told you
these were moments we could all relate
to but as a designated silver carry in
cs:go well I just can't it's never
happened to me before thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button